vice president gore thank you very much
for talking to us it's just two weeks
until cop 26 these crucial u.n climate
talks in glasgow the u.s climate envoy
has said they're probably going to fall
short how worried are you
well i think there's a lot of momentum
and i think it's likely to increase
the president of my country president
biden has made a commitment to double
the u.s contribution to the climate
finance that has long been promised to
the developing countries of the world
and the president of china xi jinping
has made a very important commitment to
completely stop the financing of all the
overseas
coal plants you have said that you're
hopeful about china it is the biggest
polluter in the world and it has also
signaled that it may actually build more
coal plants domestically and we still
don't even know if the president is
going to be attending cop26 is china
holding the talks to ransom
i wouldn't put it that way at all um i
would say that in my experience china
plans its work and then works its plan
and
when
china made its uh surprise commitment
one year ago
to reach net zero by 2060. many
people were
excited and pleased but simultaneously
disappointed that the date was so far
out but with a country of 1.4 billion
people
the majority of whom live below what
would be described in western countries
as the poverty level
it's a a big task for them so you're
still hopeful on china i am still
hopeful they just announced uh
two days ago a massive new
uh solar
installation almost as large as all of
the solar in india
and i i choose to be optimistic about it
but
china needs to do more uh every country
including my own needs to do more you
talk about doing more the queen this
week said that she is irritated by
leaders who are talking but not doing
is she right well first of all i felt
sympathy for her majesty to have what
was obviously a private conversation
picked up with boom mics and then
amplified but yes of course she's right
in terms of the us president joe biden
is sending nearly half his cabinet to
cop to cop26 he's trying to position the
country as a as a leader again and
particularly on climate and yet the us
is historically the biggest polluter and
in three years time at the next
presidential elections we may see the
paris agreement repealed again why
should anyone listen to the united
states some 55 colleges and universities
host
young republican clubs that have banded
together to demand that their party
change its position on climate the young
people are leading in my country and in
every country now and there is now a
growing demand from the grassroots
activists regardless of political party
and i think that's going to make a big
difference in the elections ahead what
are your worst fears for cop26
well i choose not to focus on
anxiety and fear about it but rather to
to be optimistic there is a lot at stake
well um
the tensions between the u.s and china
on other issues have made it
a little bit more difficult for the two
largest emitters to be aligned as they
were just before the paris agreement
but i'm still optimistic and hopeful and
the announcements just within the last
three weeks that i referred to
buttress that optimism the uk has
positioned itself as a climate leader
this year as it hope hosts these talks
cop 26 and yet greta tunberg has said
that uk is a climate villain how would
you describe the uk
well i i i first of all the uk has made
a a commitment to 68 reductions in
greenhouse gas emissions by 2030 which
is a very impressive commitment if
there's follow-through then that will
make the uk a leader such as canceling
this new
oil field development that we've heard
much about so you're saying it should be
cancelled and no more licences for oil
in the north sea i'm not a citizen of
the uk and it's not my place to
interfere in your politics but yes
that's my view
the longer we continue to dawdle
by remaining so dependent on fossil
fuels the harder it will be to make this
change so i think we need to move faster
and that to me
is consistent with just stopping these
new oil and gas and coal developments
these talks are all about trust does
boris johnson the uk prime minister
inspire the trust of other world leaders
well i think the commitment to the
massive reductions in co2 emissions by
2030 is is very impressive it's more
than the european union more than my
country more than almost any country but
commitment and action are very different
so does he inspire trust with his action
certainly true uh but the commitment can
lead to action if the people of the uk
continue to put pressure on the
government to follow through so why are
you saying yes he does inspire faith
globally
well i i think that there have been some
impressive policy changes
i will also say again the uk needs to do
more as my own country needs to do much
more
and it's been 15 years since your
seminal climate film an inconvenient
truth in it you said that you have been
trying to raise awareness of climate
change
but you felt that you had failed it's 15
years on
emissions are going up extreme weather
is getting worse do you still feel that
you've failed
well um
i feel that like everyone i need to do
more
and i've gained an appreciation for how
difficult this challenge is and the
period of time necessary to make this
historic transition
but i i think the momentum that has
emerged in the last several years since
the paris agreement
has been very impressive and i'm more
optimistic today than i was just a few
years ago